Wanda darling yes dear get
the light now that's romantic
this is our home, hello westview!
life moves pretty fast in the
suburbs something strange happened
and they happy ever after series premiere
january 15th on disney plus
Welcome to 2021, congratulations everyone you made it!
you survived2020 if you're watching this right after midnight
this morning marvel dropped this brand new
Wandavision trailer with a bunch of doctor
strange two teasers because the series is going to
cross over with doctor strange too so we'll break
it all down there's a whole bunch of avengers
stuff happening during this if you're new to the
channel i'll be doing videos for all the episodes
in a couple weeks when it starts so be sure
to subscribe to get those i'll do a disney plus
giveaway when those episodes start as well there's
also a special marvel legends tv show that's going
to air two episodes next friday and it'll be sort
of a prequel to the Wandavision episode so i'll
be doing videos for that next friday as well when
those episodes are released but during the new
footage when they're still earlier in the black
and white era of the 1950s the 1960s tv obviously
in this footage they put on a magic show what does
that remind you of with her in the top hat at what
seems like the town's park using this gazebo but
the way they have it framed and set up it's like
the tv stage is in front of a live studio audience
like during sitcoms when they'd pause for lines of
dialogue to allow the audience to laugh or react
in some way before they move on to the next scene
they actually legit filmed some of the episodes in
front of a real live studio audience you have to
imagine that the red tape that those people went
through to participate in that like we'll let you
participate in this new Wandavision series that
we're doing but if you talk about it or if you
reveal any spoilers we will take your life away
they also said that when they're doing the black
and white the older eras of tv shows like the 50s
60s and 70s they use period specific cameras from
that era to make those parts of the episodes feel
authentically old like they would have if the tv
show would have been happening during the real
life 1950s and 60s but in this scene during the
magic show she turns to vision and says something
strange happened very obvious doctor strange
reference the whole show is already confirmed to
be crossing over with doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness and setting it up like the Wandavision
finale will directly lead into the beginning
of doctor strange too multiverse of madness
also when she says something strange is happening
in this scene here it's just a reference to
the things around her changing before she actually
realizes what she's doing using her evolving
powers her infinity stone-based powers to change
reality around her as she sees fit there was even
a trailer for Wandavision that they released a
little while ago called quote-unquote reality as
in the reality stone because during a lot of these
wipe transitions don't they look exactly like the
same effect when thanos is using the reality stone
to change reality around him as he sees fit it's
like a white transition that happens in the scene
kevin feige teased that they would be taking her
full scarlet witch so this is like the mcu version
of her using her chaos magic to change things
around her warp reality as she sees fit like her
no more mutants house of m moment but you also
have to consider because the finale is supposed
to lead up to the beginning of doctor strange
to multiverse of madness in that movie isn't
happening till 2022 it seems like all these marvel
phase four disney plus shows in the movies might
be happening around the same time period instead
of the old way when things happen one right after
the other like falcon and winter soldier episodes
will start right after the Wandavision finale i
mean within a couple weeks of it but originally
that show was supposed to air before Wandavision
and maybe it doesn't matter that they switched
the order because it's all happening around
the same time period after avengers end game
and spider-man far from home i'm hoping that in
the background of one of these scenes just for
continuity when they get to the more modern era
and she's watching tv there's just something in
the background about spider-man being outed like
his identity with peter parker's face on tv and j
jonah jameson there's a lot more footage in this
that focuses on their growing family quote unquote
like her being super pregnant them with their twin
mutant children from the comics billy and tommy
in the jokes during the 1950s and 60s when they're
still in black and white about actually making the
children wanda get the light then she uses her
powers and flicks her finger bewitched style to
turn the lights off and they just start getting it
on there's a bunch more footage of them in those
crazy outfits during the 1970s 80s and 90s some of
these are going to be really crazy but also in the
background you keep hearing randall park's voice
in all these trailers is agent jimmy wu of the
fbi from ant-man and the wasp he was the one that
was trying to master close-up magic after seeing
ant-man do it i imagine that when Wandavision
picks up he won't be any better at it he's the
voice that you keep hearing broadcasting the
scarlet witch through all those radios he keeps
asking wanda are you all right who's doing this
to you notice that he doesn't ask her how vision
is doing he doesn't say anything about vision
when he's trying to find out what's happening
that's all because of how the show is set
up in the big twist with the main villain
that a lot of you have probably seen coming for
a while now if you're big x-men comic book fans
the reason why nick fury's new sword organization
monica rambo who's clearly an agent of sword
darcy from the thor movies played by kat
dennings who also seems like she's working
with sword at this point in jimmy wu with the
fbi the regular law enforcement agencies are all
tiptoeing around scarlet witch like you see them
all in this field here around this big structure
and the reason why she says to vision in present
day when they're finally in their regular modern
clothes and vision's in his avengers costume and
she starts flying off they say to each other this
is our home let's fight for it you see all the
sword vehicles and the weaponry rolling in hot
it's because no one is doing this to scarlet
witch so to speak as they think initially she's
doing it to herself because she just can't handle
vision being dead so using her evolving infinity
stone-based powers like warping reality around her
unconsciously or consciously in some instances to
make it look like she wants it to look and even
though scarlet witch isn't really a villain in the
classic sense in the context of this series she
doesn't want to leave the lie behind this house of
m alternate reality home she created for herself
even though clearly it's breaking down around
her like you start to see the cracks showing
something's wrong something's very wrong but
you have all these sword people nick fury jimmy wu
monica rambo everyone else in the main mcu reality
trying to make this all go away go back to normal
and get her to come to grips with reality vision
is dead you don't actually have children with him
and she says hell no i'm not going to do that so
it's really scarlet witch versus sword during the
series scarlet witch is kind of the villain of
the series and the protagonist at the same time
they're using a different version of that same
idea the same twist for the loki series but the
reason loki is both the hero and the villain of
his series the loki episodes is because it's the
new main loki from avengers and game that escaped
going around to alternate realities and timelines
dealing with alternate versions of himself
and because Wandavision is going to have this huge
avengers level wtf finale episode when they say
they're going to fight for their new home this
new alternate reality it implies she's going to
find a way to bring some of these fake things like
vision her children into the main mcu reality and
they'll survive paul bettany was also asked if
he's going to come back for more avengers stuff
like avengers 5 other avengers stories maybe
a Wandavision season 2 just anything else with
vision in it after these Wandavision episodes and
even though he couldn't give away big spoilers
or anything like that like will he still be dead
after the series is over what he did say is that
based on what they do during this series he says
that anything is possible and he's always happy to
come back just implying that she will find a way
to make this alternate reality version of vision
real and come back to the main mcu reality there
was also a video a while ago that elizabeth olsen
posted of her talking about the main comic book
stories that they're adapting for the series she
says that they're doing one of her favorite comic
book stories she always wanted to do is basically
house of them this is the video she posted it
is from a while ago but it gives you a pretty
good idea for the stuff that they're pulling from
for the series right she started out as a villain
her power is to tap into the
mystic powers of the universe
creating reality disrupting chaos essentially
she can manipulate cosmic probability
in house of m scarlet witch created a new reality
where mutants were the majority and magneto was
the ruler but this too backfired and scarlet witch
was forced to take action whispering the words
causing over 90 of mutants to lose their powers
there was a ton of death scarlet witch fled to one
dagor mountain disappearing from the world view
elizabeth olsen is also supposed to start going
on the talk shows next week so they'll probably be
dropping more promos and footage so of course i'll
do videos for that but leave all your Wandavision
bonus video requests in the comments below or
doctor strange bonus videos there'll be a lot of
teasers and setup easter eggs for dr strange 2
stuff happening during Wandavision so i'll just
point those out in the episodes as we see them
in my videos for the marvel legends episodes that
are going to drop next friday will post on friday
but i think that they'll be dropping the episodes
at midnight just like they did for the mandalorian
season 2 episodes so if you stay up really really
late you do have a chance to see it a little bit
before everyone else and it wouldn't be the new
year 2021 if it weren't tom holland spoiling
some spider-man stuff for us there was a really
funny video that he posted where he kind of does
spoil some stuff so i'll do a video for that next
that should post in a little while or at least by
tomorrow will you wait for everything click here
to watch mark hamill reacting to luke skywalker
in the mandalorian season 2. it's amazing and
click here for my breakdown of that brand new
marvel fantastic four teaser thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe happy new year!